Michael Myers isn't the only one cutting deep.
From human wall hangings to glasses of chocolate
milk, "Halloween Ends" is filled with easy-to-miss
details and Easter eggs. Warning: spoilers ahead!
In the movie's tragic and terrifying opening,
the hopeful prospective college student Corey
Cunningham babysits local Haddonfield child
Jeremy Allen. Before the horror begins,
Corey and Jeremy are hanging
out and having a good time.
"It's Halloween. We're gonna
have a good time tonight."
Against the wishes of the Allens, Corey is
being a little lax and letting Jeremy watch
scary movies with him. On that Halloween
Night, it's John Carpenter's "The Thing."
Not only is the scene of these two watching
"The Thing" an obvious nod to Carpenter,
director of "The Thing" and the original
"Halloween," but it has another layer to
it as well. In the 1978 "Halloween," there is
a scene of Laurie and the kid she is looking
after watching "The Thing." Of course, they
aren't watching Carpenter's 1982 masterpiece,
since he hadn't made it yet. The movie shown
in the original was 1951's "The Thing from
Another World," which Carpenter adapted and
reimagined for the '80s. Pretty fitting,
considering the new "Halloween" trilogy is
also a reimagining of the Michael Myers story.
Corey Cunningham becomes an outcast
after the night he accidentally kills
Jeremy Allen. On the night of the accident,
Corey even had a chance to drink a beer but
opts for chocolate milk to accompany his
dessert. Ultimately he never got a chance
to drink the milk. Years later, he buys
chocolate milk at a gas station. Afterward,
a group of teens asks him to buy them
beer, once again bringing Corey's drink
of choice into question. But why exactly is
chocolate milk important to "Halloween Ends"?
There are a couple of themes that could tie
into why Corey drinks chocolate milk. For one,
it makes him different from others, reinforcing
his feeling of being an outcast. But his taste
for chocolate milk, a drink usually associated
with children, is the important part here. This
shows that on the inside, he is still more
of a child than he is an adult. Corey is a
scared kid who never had a chance to grow up, and
Michael Myers preys on this to unleash his evil.
Since this is "Halloween Ends," the story
of Laurie and Michael, appropriately,
comes to a conclusion. As such, the movie pays
appropriate homage to where the story began. One
visual callback that works on multiple levels is
just one of many references to John Carpenter's
low-budget 1978 horror classic, a moment
where Corey Cunningham imitates Michael Myers.
Corey becomes a sort of disciple of Michael,
enacting murders in Haddonfield after a chance
meeting with Michael in the sewers. But the
earliest visual hint that Corey is going down this
dark path is when he imitates the slasher villain,
peeking out from behind a bush. Eagle-eyed fans of
the original "Halloween" will recognize this as a
reference to an early shot in that film of Michael
Myers in the exact same position. It's one of the
first glimpses we get of the character, as Laurie
walks down the sidewalk on an otherwise completely
normal fall day. The shot of Michael peeking
out from behind a hedge has become an iconic
image from the very first movie in the series.
Sondra Dickerson is a minor character who winds
up surviving all three modern "Halloween" movies.
There was some speculation over whether or
not Sondra had died in the scene where Michael
attacked her and her husband in "Halloween
Kills." In that film, Sondra gets one of the
most grotesque, painful encounters with Michael
Myers, watching him attack and kill her husband
and standing in terror as he puts a tube light
in her neck. Now, in "Halloween Ends," we see she
has survived, but has been rendered disabled
by Michael's attack and is in a wheelchair.
In one scene, Sondra's friend Stacy
confronts Laurie in a parking lot
and blames her for her friend's condition
and the death of Sondra's husband. Later,
when the town is carrying Michael to his final
resting place, we get a brief shot showing us
that Sondra is still around. She survived the
events of "Halloween Ends," making her one of
the lucky few throughout the franchise to
survive an encounter with Michael Myers.
A great little trick in scary movies is when the
slasher or monster is lurking in the background
of a shot, almost imperceptible. Terrifying
if done right, this trick can frighten and
foreshadow future events for those who notice.
It can also add rewatch value for anyone who
missed it the first time. When it's pulled off in
"Halloween Ends," it also has a deeper meaning,
since this is a trope the series
uses constantly with Michael Myers.
In one sequence, Corey lures a cop who used to
date Allyson to Michael Myers' hiding place in
a sewer underneath Haddonfield. When "Halloween
Ends" first pulls this trick, you see Michael in
the background, foreshadowing the man's fate.
However, in a similar shot almost immediately
after the first, we now see Corey lurking in
the background of the shot in the same way.
It's another hint of where his arc is going and
the similarities he is developing with Michael.
"Show me how to do it."
Every slasher movie needs a character
who exists just for the purpose of being
senselessly murdered. That appears
to be the purpose of Nurse Deb,
Allyson's annoying coworker in "Halloween
Ends." When it's shown that she is sleeping
with their boss, Dr. Mathis, which is why
Deb received a promotion over Allyson,
Michael Myers and his protégé show up
for some good old-fashioned slashing.
While Mathis is taken care of by Corey outside,
Deb is trapped inside the house with Michael.
When she is killed, Michael pins her to the
wall. It's a direct callback to a kill from
the 1978 original. In "Halloween," Michael
kills Bob by stabbing him and pinning him to
a cabinet with a kitchen knife. Deb meets a
similar fate, albeit stabbed in a different
place. "Halloween Ends" even puts the cherry
on top by having Michael childishly cock his
head to the side in wonder or curiosity
the same way he does in the original.
In the original "Halloween,"
during their first encounter,
Michael slashes Laurie on the arm, which
causes her to stumble and fall over the
banister on the top floor of the Wallace
house. Bleeding and dizzy from the fall,
Laurie barely manages to escape. But "Halloween
Ends" reverses the roles and changes the outcome.
In the finale of David Gordon Green's
trilogy, it's Corey who falls over the
stairway banister. He is dressed, at this point,
in full Michael Myers attire after stealing the
mask. At the end of the movie, Laurie fakes
her own suicide to lure Corey to her. Then,
she reveals her trap and shoots Corey, sending him
over the banister of her house. The shot of him
falling echoes Laurie's fall in the original,
but this time the roles are reversed. Even if
Corey is not actually Michael, the visual imagery
of him dressed as Michael Myers serves as a role
reversal for these characters, showing how much
Laurie has grown since the 1978 "Halloween."
One of Laurie's biggest moments of victory in
John Carpenter's "Halloween" is when she stabs a
knitting needle into Michael Myers' neck after he
breaks into the Doyle home. After she stabs him,
he goes down for a brief moment, incapacitated.
Viewers at the time surely thought maybe he
was dead, but "Halloween" fans these days
know he was just resting up for round two.
In another reversal of Laurie and
Michael's roles as predator and prey,
it is not Michael who gets stabbed when
"Halloween Ends" eventually references the
knitting needle scene. During their final scuffle
in Laurie's home, Michael grabs a knitting needle
and stabs Laurie. Maybe it's payback from
over 40 years ago. Of course, maybe Michael
is just looking for the most convenient way to
kill his rival. Regardless of why it happens,
this moment is a fun twist on a callback
that would otherwise be a bit too obvious.
If you watched David Gordon Green's 2018
"Halloween," you may remember Julian. He
is also known as the hardest kid in the
world to babysit. A hilarious addition to
"Halloween," is that Julian managed to survive
an attack by Michael Myers. His babysitter,
Vicky, and her boyfriend were not as
lucky. Though babysitters rarely are.
"You go up there, you're gonna get killed, Dave!"
Julian was confirmed to have survived Myers'
killing spree in "Halloween," but he doesn't
show up in "Halloween Ends" until one
of the final scenes. In that scene,
the movie confirms that Sondra lived and
shows other minor characters from the trilogy,
like Lindsey Wallace, getting their final
vengeance on Michael. In this montage of
the people of Haddonfield accompanying Laurie in
a procession, we get a glimpse of Julian. Just
knowing he survived all the horrible nights
in Haddonfield is enough to warm our hearts.
Pumpkins and pumpkin pie are pretty universal
symbols for fall and especially the Halloween
season. The same can be said of
the "Halloween" movies. Pumpkins
are often a symbol of the series as well,
appearing in the opening credits sequences
of all the David Gordon Green movies as
an homage to the opening credits of John
Carpenter's original film. This pumpkin
imagery comes full circle at the end.
Early on in the movie, Laurie burns a pie.
She tells Allyson she's trying to bake her a
pumpkin pie because it is her favorite dessert
during this time of year. After all the stress
of Michael's final killing spree, the serial
killer is supposedly dead and disposed of,
and we see a period of peace in Haddonfield.
Allyson recovers from the trauma and prepares
to begin her life anew; in the background
of the shot sits a delicious-looking slice
of pumpkin pie. A fitting bit of
closure to her terrifying story.